aujourd'hui c'était journée morte dans
les pharmacies croix verte et vitrines
éteinte
une action symbolique lancée à
l'initiative de l'union nationale des
pharmacies de france afin d'attirer
l'attention des patients sur les
difficultés financières des pharmaciens
il ya beaucoup de produits qui sont
passés de 35 à 15% de remboursement il y
à des baisses des prix des médicaments
parce que maintenant les marges des
pharmaciens au niveau national on est à
23 23 et demi pour cent voilà il ya
encore quelques années on était plutôt
autour de 30% de de bénéfices après
juste sur le chiffre d'affaires mais
donc voilà donc c'est une la marge a
énormément diminué
et puis les coups à côté restent les
mêmes donc c'est vrai que c'est
difficile
et au final le système de marges
bénéficiaires qui prévoit que plus un
médicament est cher plus la part
accordée aux pharmaciens est faible a de
lourdes conséquences sur la profession à
une période où les prix des médicaments
et les volumes vendus sont en baisse
ainsi ce sont en moyenne de pharmacies
qui met la clé sous la porte chaque
semaine
une situation d'autant plus inquiétante
en milieu rural dans certains villages
il y a plus de médecins et les gens si
la pharmacie de mais ferme et serait
venu avec les conséquences d'une
diminution du nombre de pharmacies ses
mimiques catastrophique puisque
aujourd'hui on a un minimum de sept
kilomètres pour trouver une pharmacie on
pourrait doubler cette distance ça veut
dire 15 km et pour certaines personnes
âgées certaines personnes à mobilité
réduite ce serait vraiment très
difficile de trouver des médicaments une
séance de négociations entre les
organisations syndicales et le ministère
de la santé est prévue pour le 25
octobre une date qui ne convient pas aux
pharmaciens puisque le projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale pour
2011 sera déjà à l'étude
impossible alors de faire modifier le
système des marges bénéficiaires en
place depuis dix ans